art et agriculture pays ce sont ces deux
mondes qui ont donné à voir et à
déguster au coeur du jardin de l'état
pour offrir aux visiteurs les meilleurs
produits du terroir et de l'artisanat
local
un marché de fruits de légumes mais
également de confiture de miel ou encore
de vanille et de la qualité s'il vous
plaît avec des productions bio ou issus
de l'agriculture raisonnée pour les
produire que j'ai que vous voyez là
c'est des produits et j'ai bien sans
enlever
je fais ça dérape par exemple petites
pommes de terre nouvelles de carottes en
mode la carotte pays que des produits
des agriculteurs qui peuvent grâce à ce
marché pays vendre directement leur
production consommateurs c'est pour cela
que lisette maillot a fait le choix de
devenir agricultrice elle veut faire la
promotion de ses produits mais surtout
proposer des fruits et légumes
différents et en exclusivité le sait ce
que vend dans l'économie du port r&b du
couvent mais cherche que lapointe ce
marché quoi donc cessé de défrayer un
petit peu à droite à gauche qu'il n'ya
pas sur le marché et me ramène aussi
hélas pour le gazole en est aujourd'hui
bien la maladie et bâle en quarts et
après les conflits plus près que ça
le marché pays et des étals qui font le
bonheur des visiteurs
oui c'est bien ça fait plaisir de voilà
de devoir les légumes du pays c'est bio
c'est très agréable
et puis ces bouts de voir tout ça à
toutes ces couleurs de ses faveurs qu'on
voit c'est la première fois que je viens
ici d'adam se manger ici donc c'est
beaucoup plus sympathique beaucoup plus
agréable un nouveau plus vert de l'autre
côté du jardin ont rendez vous avec les
herbages pays des plantes médicinales
qui continuent à guérir des générations
de réunionnais pour l'association arts
et traditions de marché pays est une
vitrine incontournable pour favoriser la
promotion des artisans locaux quoi cette
première participation c'est le point de
chute idéal pour l'asl association aider
les artisans à se faire connaître le
site est merveilleux l'accueil conseil
départemental idéal les conditions sont
réunies pour que les artisans puissent
enfin s'exposer pourra faire la
promotion développer leurs connaissances
qu'on a mis en place aussi des ateliers
pédagogiques
donc pour nous c'est celle à une
situation idéale un marché pays rempli
de petits trésors comme cette nouveauté
ce trio de piment destiné à la jeune
marie c'est à dire elle va passer en
plus membre il qui enfant ensuite on va
pas à miner on va passer le k qu'il a et
puis elle va rester tranquille et c'est
le droit de voter impeccable les gens
les ravis de prendre le trio cas pilote
pour ceux qui ont raté la corbeille de
la mariée rendez vous le 12 septembre à
l'espace ridley pour le prochain marché
pays
pour les inconditionnels du jardin de
l'état ça se passera le 19 décembre
prochain